لم أستطع الانتظار حتى أركب دراجة
بمجرد وصولي
[موسيقى] ،
لست مضطرًا لأن أكون مقتنعًا بالقدوم إلى
كوبنهاغن
بالنظر إلى أفق
كوبنهاجن
مندهشًا من مدى تميزه
باستثناء أبراج الكنيسة ربما
التي هي رائعة
ولكن لا يتم
تضليلها داخل هذا المشهد
البسيط ، هناك أشخاص وأماكن ذات شخصية رائعة نريد استكشافها لتكون في كوبنهاغن هي أن تكون مرتاحًا وهذا شيء مثير مثل جسر يصعد
وقاربًا
في بلد يبدو أنه
سيطر على الحياة الطبيعية المرغوبة من نوع ما ، فقد
وصل
هذا ما يجب أن يبدو عليه المحرك كما لو
أن الدنماركيين قد أتقنوا شكلاً رسميًا غير
رسمي يمزج التقاليد
مع
الملكية الدنماركية المعاصرة التي يعود تاريخها إلى أكثر
من ألف عام ، لكنها أيضًا حديثة
حتى  ولي العهد الأميرة هي
قصة خرافية عامة بالنسبة للملكية
لا يمكنني الذهاب بعيدًا في كوبنهاغن قبل أن
أسمع ذات مرة
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا
ريتشارد ومرحبًا بكم في
مرحبًا عاصمة  من حكاية العالم الخيالية
إلى
العاصمة الشتوية للعالم بالتأكيد أنا سعيد
جدًا برؤيتك ومن
لدينا هنا من لدينا هنا يمكنك رؤية الكثير من
الشخصيات إبهاملينا هذه هي
الأميرة و p وهنا لدينا  صاحب
السمو الملكي ، الإمبراطور الذي
يرتدي ،
لا شيء على الإطلاق ، إنه يمشي هناك
في كل ما لديه معًا
في ثوانٍ ، لقد عدت إلى
أقنعة الطفولة مع توربين إيفرسون مقنعًا
حيث قام مؤلف القصص الخيالية بتسليم كريستيان
أندرسون عازف
الطبول وسنذهب إلى قلعة القصص الخيالية
الآن  واحد اثنان واحد اثنان تعال نعم نعم نعم
لدينا إمبراطور جديد معنا
ليس لدي أي فكرة عن كيفية حدوث ذلك لي
نعم أنا قادم
موكبًا من القصص الخيالية إلى
قلعة خيالية مع شخصيات رائعة
مباشرة من
الجنية بالطبع  حكايات
كايسون النووية للإمبراطور
[تصفيق]
كنت أقوم بعمل كريستيان
أندرسون طوال حياتي تقريبًا لماذا
من المفترض أن يكون أشهر داين على
الإطلاق
يجب على أي شخص القيام به لتمثيل
أندرسون للسفر  العالم لتقديم
القصص وأنا لم تدعي أنك تشبهه على
الرغم من أنني
أعتقد أنك لا أقول للناس إنني أندرسون
ألعب أنا أندرسون لأن أندرسون
قال للمسافرين أن أعيش وأقول أن اللعب هو
عش هذا ما أفعله
السيد أندرسون ، نعم ، هذه الفكرة في الحياة اللاحقة ،
لا يزال لدينا خيال ،
ما الذي تحاول أن تخبرني به ، سأخبرك
أنك ستجعل حياتك دائمًا
قصة خيالية
إذا كنت تتذكر أن هذا سيكون
أهم شيء في
بعض القصص الخيالية أنها ليست مظلمة
بقدر ما لها ميزة ، ألا
يجب عليك أن تدرك أنها ذات
ألوان سوداء ومشرقة
في كتاب القصص الخيالية عن حياتك ،
فأنت محق في أعمال شغب  حفلة ألست أنت
يا
[موسيقى]
ما الذي تعتقد أن الناس يخرجون منه
يحصلون على الفيتامينات لحياتهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تحت تعويذة الحكايات ضباب
من
الوقت أعلم أنه أي شيء آخر أكتشفه
رائعًا
كوبنهاغن بالنسبة لي